Saludos Rodrigo como ves todo listo aquí
en el Palacio de la Eliseo la guardia
republicana desplegada para recibir al
presidente de Ucrania boludo mercedesky
y al canciller Federal de Alemania olas
chores el objetivo de Esta visita según
la presidencia francesa es demostrar el
apoyo indefectible de Francia a Ucrania
y también demostrar la utilidad de ese
mecanismo que permite responder a los
intereses y las necesidades de kiev en
el terreno de manera reactiva y
eficiente es una visita importante si
tenemos en cuenta dos aspectos primero
desde el punto de vista histórico faltan
apenas un par de semanas para que se
cumpla el primer aniversario del inicio
de la guerra y es importante que
occidente demuestre unidad y apoyo a
Ucrania pero sobre todo el terreno
continúan esas batallas sangrientas en
el este de Ucrania es decir que Rusia
continúa avanzando continúa su ofensiva
pero sobre todo hay recientes informes
de inteligencia que indican que la
armada de Vladimir Putin organiza un
gran ofensiva una ofensiva masiva que
pudiera ser según el secretario general
de la organización del tratado del
Atlántico Norte James stoltenberg a
finales del invierno o incluso antes de
manera que de la parte ucraniana por
supuesto el objetivo va a ser obtener
compromisos para el envío de más
armamento armamento que permita repeler
esa invasión en Rusia viene voló de
Reino Unido Donde ha logrado al menos un
compromiso importante el envío de esos
tanques pesados Challenger 2 a finales
de marzo y por lo menos no se ha negado
el reino británico a enviar
posteriormente aviones ya sabemos que se
ha acordado el entrenamiento de pilotos
es decir que esa también es otra
posibilidad
Luis Miguel además hace poco Alemania
confirmó también el envío de los
leopardos a Ucrania que se sabe Ahora
sobre los tanques franceses leclerc se
piensa enviar también estos tanques
hasta el momento el gobierno francés no
ha expresado ninguna posición concreta
en lo que respecta a esos tanques
pesados sabemos que ya en el terreno la
armada francesa el gobierno francesa ha
enviado tanques ligeros es decir si
vemos las imágenes la diferencia es que
los ligeros son esos que tienen
neumáticos y Los Pesados los que tienen
esteras pero Francia también ha enviado
hasta el momento armamento a Ucrania
sabemos que hay también Los cañones
César que es una defensa antiaérea y la
cereza en el pastel como decía en el mes
pasado el ministro de defensa ucraniano
que es ese radar gm200 que permite
localizar aviones y drones a 250
kilómetros de distancia los principios
que tiene Francia para dotar ayuda aquí
es que parten de esas declaraciones de
Manuel macron que dicen que todo está
sobre la mesa cuando se trata de ayudar
a Ucrania son resistir a la invasión es
decir que la ayuda francesa debe
permitir que Ucrania resista a la
invasión que no contribuya a una
escalada del conflicto que sea
coordinada con los aliados de París y
occidente y que no debilite las
capacidades defensivas de Francia es
decir que en cualquier caso la ayuda
debe cumplir con esas condiciones y los
detalles los tendremos probablemente más
adentrada la noche desde aquí desde el
palacio del división